we end with a sparkler let me get a drum
roll please
only on cbs mornings we have an
exclusive in studio look at the
largest white diamond ever to go
on auction this is jackie
and she is here to show off the diamond
known as the rocket weighs more than
228 carats about as much as a golf ball
it is expected folks to go for up to 30
million dollars so that's auctions
you basically have to be the rock in
order to report
exactly it's part of the magnificent
jewels collection that will be shown
during christie's luxury week in geneva
and switzerland and guess what uh
chandler gould who's producing this
segment she had to emphasize an email
several times vlad you are not allowed
to touch it i got that email but john
tower just said to me you have a shot
grab it and go yeah
you have security here i was going to
say do you have armed security so
anybody who's watching it right now as
you like
and they have guns don't everybody have
any ideas what did you say it was
my man pulling out his wallet ready to
go you left it upstairs
is it heavy is it heavy it is would you
like to hold it can we wait
[Laughter]
it's about the size of a chicken egg to
give you guys an idea
what would you say are you looking
forward
my hands are shaking and then what would
you do with it jack you make a necklace
of that a ring
i don't trust you in your hands
um it actually is accompanied by a
pendant mount so it was worn on a
necklace at one point but you know what
what makes this so expensive besides its
massive size so just look at it it's
really rare we gotta get up out of here
we'll talk about in the commercial break